That you tend to climb with your hands too low,
break legs or simply use
1 hand more than the other,
this video is for you.
So here we go!
Today we work on the position of the hands
and we'll need a whip.
So you're gonna come wedge your whip between your legs
and the reins.
So
it's clearly your legs that hold the whip
and so it will try to mount the
hands too low
or break the legs
or remove 1 more than another.
Of course,
we are in 1 exercise,
which means it will change your position,
change your habits,
potentially change your balance
and therefore change your horse's reactions.
So don't worry,
if the first 3 minutes,
nothing seems normal,
this is the case.
Nothing is normal because you change your position.
Don't worry,
try to relax as best you can
and continue your work.
Me personally,
I noticed that I start to break my wrist
when I want to resume,
i.e. braking.
So here we go,
work on this,
move on,
come back,
we move on,
we come back.
Of course,
I don't think we can have 1 clear transition
and it is wanted,
this is quite normal.
As I explained,
I change my balance.
So it would be totally
selfish to ask my horse to be perfect
and answer perfectly well
while I am still looking for myself in my
Position and in my hands
so I make progressive requests
but the goal is to have 1 more and more gallop
fast and longer and longer
in real life guys for,
it is cool this exo